this morning we bring you a remarkable
story of hope and perseverance Antonio
Davis was shot 24 years ago in one of
Chicago's roughest neighborhoods it
nearly killed him Davis overcame his
damaging injuries to become a successful
painter he also found love along the way
DeMarco Morgan spoke with him about that
journey DeMarco good morning good
morning Antonio Davis
showed us his life was headed in the
wrong direction when he was shot at
close range back in 1994 what he did
know was that it's life was about to
take an extraordinary turn with purpose
I'm just creating I'm just freeing my
mind and what comes out is my true
emotions through his oil paintings
Antonio Davis brings to life his burning
desire to create his a passion is an
obsession I love it that much and I hope
it shows in the work his work that
includes landscapes still lifes and
portraits but the picture comes from a
different perspective
the 43 old paints with his mouth when
Davis was 19 years old his friend shot
him during a fight he was left paralyzed
from his chest down when you learned
that you were paralyzed do you think
life was over for you at least the way
that you had lived it absolutely I
didn't know anything about people in
wheelchairs I didn't have a
comprehension of the physical
requirements of the daily living with
somebody with their quality of life
so the teenager was placed at our
nursing home to learn how to adjust to
his new wheelchair-bound life and was
there that he met Juanita Butler I
noticed him and I said oh my god you're
so gorgeous what are you doing here he
says I live here oh so she came onto you
yeah she was aggressive very aggressive
very aggressive and she's like I'm gonna
get you out of here she did get him out
of there and a year later they got
married I made the best choice in the
world
when I said I'm getting you out of this
nursing home I found somebody who's so
special who's like a diamond in the
rough and now he's shining
shining through his art something he's
always loved but only pursued after the
incident I try art with my hands using
different devices and how did that work
for you for me it worked fine I thought
that I was doing well but for others it
did an occupational therapist suggested
he tried with his mouth so after some
convincing he did fifteen years later
his paintings are recognized worldwide
and range in price from five to more
than 80 thousand dollars most don't
believe it
because the level that I have gotten to
in my artistry it's where they say you
didn't paint that with your mouth
dave was presented a portrait of former
President Barack Obama to the man
himself what did he think of the picture
that you did for all he loved it the
first response was I love that you
didn't put the gray hair in there so the
artists also gives back he volunteers
his time to teach and inspire art
students on Chicago's South Side at
Richard J Daly Community College I feel
like me going out mouth painting showing
the public the community that you can
have a tragic accident it looks good or
any tragedy that happened to you and you
still can be able to accomplish things
have you ever asked the question why me
no I always dare myself to do better
just do better that's it have you
forgiven the man who shot you
your friend absolutely I have forgave
him and I have forgave the spirit behind
it so his own spirit within could
inspire those around him you just do
what you just do what I do
I just get up and do what I do when
today when two week when the month when
de year when your life
quality certainly has antonio toda said
the shooting was a blessing in disguise
had he not been in the nursing home he
may not have ever met his wife Juanita
and if he wasn't paralyzed and may have
never pursued his passion for it and you
know guys this is a life changing story
for me because it really proves that no
matter the setbacks that come in your
life you can still win and win because I
found love and he's doing what he go
home in sorter to do what was she doing
in the nursing home did she work there
she had a relative there okay so it's an
unbelievable story tomorrow it's one of
those beautiful stories are being told
on the show and we use the phrase and in
the piece the phrase wheelchair-bound
but that looks like freedom to me that
looks like creativity looks like
Tennessee getting higher well you know
what it also proves that happiness and
peace is what matters at the end of the
day so true and the power of people
believing in you and you believing in
yourself do thank you thank you